สวัสดีค่ะครูชี้สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
สวัสดีค่ะทุกๆคนค่ะวันนี้เราสองคนก็มาเจอ
กันที่ห้องเรียน Complete  hensible ไทย
นะคะห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
แล้ววันนี้
ครูปุ๊กเราสองคนมาเจอกันวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายนค่ะ
เดือนมิถุนายนเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะ
เป็นเดือนที่ 6 ค่ะ
แล้วปีนี้เนี่ยเป็นปี
พุทธศักราชเท่าไหร่คะ
หรือบางครั้งเราก็พูด 2  5  6  6 ใช่ไหม
คะ
ใช่ค่ะค่ะแล้วเป็นปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่า
ไหร่คะ
ปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะ
2,023 นะ 2023
2566 ปีคริสต์ศักราช
2023 ค่ะใช่ค่ะแล้ววันนี้ค่ะ
อ่าให้นักเรียนเนี่ยฟัง
วันนี้เราจะคุยตัวเราค่ะ
ร่างกาย
ร่างกายหรอคะ
จะเปรียบเทียบคนกับสัตว์
ก็คือ
อย่างข้างหลังครูกุ๊กก็จะมีสัตว์ตัวหนึ่ง
ชื่อแมวใช่ไหม
คะแล้วแล้วเราจะเปรียบเทียบอะไรกับมันล่ะ
คะ
กับสัตว์ทั้งหลายเนี่ย
อยากเปรียบเทียบ
เราเนี่ยเดินด้วยอะไรคะ
เราก็เดินได้ค่ะ
นี่
แล้วเรามีกี่ขาคะ
คนเนี่ยนะคะเราก็มี 1 คนเนี่ยมี 2 ขาค่ะ
เราเนี่ยมีขา 1  2  1
2  1  2 อ๋อไม่มีใครมี 3 ใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะไม่ว่าจะเป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงใช่
ไหมก็มีคนละ 2 ขาค่ะ
ผู้ชายก็ 2 ขาผู้หญิงก็ 2 ขา
ไม่ว่าจะเป็น
คนไทย
ก็คนไทยคนไทยก็มี 2 ขาค่ะ
ไม่ว่าจะคนชาติไหนก็มี 2 ขาไม่ว่าผู้ชาย
ไม่ว่าผู้หญิงก็มี 2 นะคะ
แล้วก็เทียบกับสัตว์
อะไรคะหรือ
อย่างถ้าเกิดเป็นตัวนี้ล่ะคะ
งู
[ปรบมือ]
มีขาไหม
จากที่ครูนะ
งูอ่ะไม่มีขาค่ะ
เอ้าครูชิงูไม่มีขาแล้วงูจะเดินได้ยังไง
อ่ะคะ
งูไม่เดินค่ะ
แล้วงูจะไปไกลๆก็ไปไม่ได้เหรอคะ
งูเลื้อยค่ะ
เลื้อย
งูเลื้อยงูไม่เดิน
เพราะว่างูไม่มีขาใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะงูเนี่ยไม่มีขาค่ะ
งูมีขาเป็น 0
คนเนี่ย
มี 2 ขา
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยคนเนี่ยมีขา
มากกว่างู
งูมีขา
น้อยกว่าคนค่ะ
น้อยกว่า
ค่ะ
แล้วมีสัตว์อะไรที่ไม่มีขาอีกไหมพรูชิมี
ปลาค่ะ
ปลาก็ไม่มีขาค่ะคุณปุ๊กเอ้าแล้วมันไปยัง
ไงล่ะคะมันจะเดินไปไหนยังไง
ปลาเนี่ยไม่เลื้อยเหมือนงู
ปลาเนี่ยว่ายน้ำ
[เพลง]
ปลาเนี่ยว่ายน้ำค่ะ
เพราะว่าปลาเนี่ยมันมีหางค่ะ
ใช่แล้วมันก็มีครีบครีบ
ครีบ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมันใช้หางนะ
แล้วก็ใช้ครีบในการที่ว่ายน้ำมันเลยไม่
ต้องมีขา
มันก็เลยไม่ต้องมีขาเหมือนกับคนค่ะ
เพราะว่าปลาเนี่ยไม่ได้อยู่บนพื้นดิน
เหมือนเราใช่ไหมนะอาศัยอยู่ในน้ำ
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยถ้าเดินในน้ำน่าจะไม่
สบายค่ะ
[เพลง]
มีอีกตัวค่ะอันนี้
เรียกว่าอะไรคะครูปุ๊กหอยทากค่ะบลูชิหอย
ทากแล้วหอยทากมีขาไหมคะครูชิหอยทากก็ไม่
มีขาค่ะ
แล้วมันเลื้อยเหมือนงูไหมคะ
มันไม่เลื้อยเหมือนงูค่ะ
มันว่ายน้ำเหมือนปลาไหมคะ
มันไม่ว่ายน้ำแบบปลาค่ะ
เอาแล้วมันไปยังไงคะ
[เพลง]
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยบางทีเนี่ยสัตว์ก็ไม่
ต้องมีขาก็ได้นะมันก็สามารถไปได้มันไม่
ต้องเดินมันอาจจะเลื้อยไปมันอาจจะว่ายน้ำ
ไปมันอาจจะกระดึ๊บกระดึ๊บกระดึ๊บกระดึ๊บ
ไปก็ได้เอ้อ
ก็ไปได้นะคนเนี่ยถ้าไม่มีขาน่าจะเหนื่อย
นะคะ
[เพลง]
ถ้าเราเป็นคนเนี่ยแล้วเราไม่มีขาเรา
เลื้อยแบบงูได้ไหม
โอ้โหไม่ดีค่ะน่าจะสกปรกค่ะที่พื้นไม่
โอเคค่ะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
นะ
ถ้าเราไม่มีขานะถ้าเราไม่มีขาเราหรอก
ค่ะ
ก็จะนั่งรถวีลแชร์ไง
เพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยหอยทากปลาแล้วก็งูเนี่ย
ไม่มีขา
เพราะฉะนั้นคนมี 2 ขาคนก็เลยมีขามากกว่า
หอยทากมีขามากกว่าปลามีขามากกว่างู
ใช่ไหม
แล้ว
อย่างนั้นเนี่ย
มันก็มีตัวที่มีขาเหมือนๆกับคนสิคะมี 2
ขา
ไก่เนี่ยมีขา 1  2
ไก่มีขาเหมือนคนเลยค่ะ
ครูปุ๊ก
ใช่มี 2 ขาค่ะ
เข้ากัน
ไม่มากกว่าไม่น้อยกว่าเท่ากัน
เดินได้เหมือนคนนะเดินๆๆ
นะ
ตัวนี้นะคะ
เป็ดค่ะ
เป็ดเป็ดก็มี 1  2 มี 2 ขาเหมือนกัน
เหมือนๆไก่
เหมือนๆคน
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าเป็ดเนี่ยขาเป็ดว่ายน้ำได้
ด้วยนะครูชิเออ
แล้ว
ขาเป็ดเนี่ย 1  2  3 แล้วก็มีแบบนี้ใช่
ไหม
อันนี้เป็นเท้ามันใช่ไหม
ใช่สำหรับว่ายน้ำนะมันเลยว่ายน้ำเก่งโอ้
ขาเป็ดเนี่ยเหมือนเหมือนหางปลาเลยค่ะ
เหมือนๆกันค่ะเหมือนๆหางปลา
มันเลยว่ายน้ำเก่ง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เท่ากับคนเลย
[เพลง]
1  2  8  1  2 โอ๊ยเท่ากับครูปุ๊กเท่า
กับครูชี้เท่ากัน
แล้วตัวนี้ล่ะคะ
นกก็มี 2 ขาค่ะบลูชิ 1  2
นกก็มีขา
2 ขา
เหมือนๆกับคนเหมือนๆกับเป็ดเหมือนๆกับไก่
นะ
มีขาเท่ากัน
มีอะไรที่มีขามากกว่าคนมากกว่าไก่เป็ดนก
ไหมคะ
เหมือนคนเลยค่ะ
กลัวอะไรคะ
2 ขาค่ะ 1  2
คือชี้ขาขวาให้ยายภาพใหญ่หน่อยค่ะ
ดูขาแมวชัดๆค่ะ
นี่ 1  2
อ่ะข้างบนก็เป็นขาค่ะแมวเนี่ยมี 4 ขาค่ะ
ครูชิอันนี้ขาหรอคะอ้าวไม่ใช่แขนหรอ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
เพราะว่าแมวเนี่ยเวลาเดินเนี่ยมันจะเดิน
เนี่ย 4 ขาค่ะ
นะแล้วก็เลยเรียกว่าขาหน้าขาหลังไม่เรียก
แขนค่ะเป็นขาหน้านะขาหน้า 2 ขาหลัง 2 นะ
ก็เป็น 4 ขาค่ะแมวเนี่ยมี 4 ขาค่ะ
พอมีขาหน้า 2 แล้วก็มีขาหลัง 2 ก็เท่ากับ
4 ขา
อ้าวครูชี้คิดว่าขาเนี่ยมี 1 ขาเนี่ยมี 2
2 อันข้างบนเนี่ยคิดว่าเป็นแขนแขน
เราไม่เรียกแขนค่ะเพราะว่าสัตว์เนี่ยมัน
ใช้เดินทั้ง 4 ใช่ไหมมันก็เลยเป็น
ขาทั้ง 4 ขา
แมวก็เลยมี 4 ขา
แล้วตัวนี้ล่ะคะ
อ๋อเวลาแมวเดินมันจะเดินแบบนี้ใช่ไหม 4
ขาใช่
นะอันนี้ม้าค่ะม้า
มี 1
4 ขา
ใช่ค่ะน้ำ
ก็เหมือนกันกับแมวมีขาหน้าสองขาขาหลัง 2
ขาเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมันก็เลยมี 4 ขาค่ะ
มีทั้งหมด 4 ขาม้า
แมวอันนี้มีขามากกว่าคน
แนวม้ามีขาเท่ากัน
เท่ากัน
เอ้า
อันนี้ก็อีกแล้วอ่ะ
ครูปุ๊กตกลงอันนี้เหมือนคนหรือเหมือน
แมวคะมันมีแขนใช่ไหม
หมาก็เหมือนแมวค่ะนะเหมือนแมวเหมือนม้า
เวลาเดินใช้ 4 ขาเหมือนกัน
อันนี้ก็คือ 1  2
3  4
ใช่นะก็จะมีขาหน้าสองขาขาหลัง 2 ขาก็เป็น
4 ขาค่ะ
อันนี้เนี่ย 4 ขา
หมา
นะคะหมา
ต้องฟังเสียงดีๆนะหมา
หมาแมว
แมว
หมา
[เพลง]
แมวมี 4 ขาเหมือนกัน
มีอะไรที่มากกว่า 4 ขาไหมคะหรือชี้มีค่ะ
อันนี้ค่ะมีช้างค่ะ
2  3  4  5
ช้างเนี่ยมี 5 ขาค่ะครูปุ๊กไม่ใช่ค่ะครู
ชิ
ครูชิเนี่ยมองดีๆนะขยายให้ใหญ่ขึ้นค่ะ
ย้ายใหญ่ขึ้นใหญ่ขึ้นใหญ่ขึ้นใหญ่ขึ้น
เห็นไหมข้างหน้าเนี่ยไม่ใช่ขาค่ะเป็นงวง
ของช้างกับงวงค่ะนะเป็นงวงอันนี้คืองวง
ไม่ใช่ขา
เพราะฉะนั้นมี 1
3 แล้วก็ 4
อันนี้คือหางอันนี้คือม่วง
แต่มีขา
ง่วงของฉันเนี่ยใช้จับอะไรแล้วก็เอาเข้า
ปากได้ค่ะเอากล้วยเข้าปากนะเหมือนมือค่ะ
งวงก็เหมือนมือนะหรือว่าบางทีก็มีน้ำดูด
น้ำได้แล้วก็พ่นน้ำ
มีกล้วยแล้วก็เอากล้วยเนี่ยเข้าปากใช่
[เพลง]
อันนั้นเป็น
ไม่ใช่ขา
ไม่ใช่ขาขามีแค่ 4 ค่ะ
ตรงนี้อีกอันนึงค่ะ
ไม่มีค่ะ
ใช่มีแค่ 4 ขาค่ะขาหน้าสองขาหันสองขาค่ะ
นะเพราะฉะนั้น
ช้างหรือหมา
แมว
[เพลง]
หมาก็มี 4 ขาเท่ากัน
แมวหมาหมา
ช้างมี 4 ขา
มีขามากกว่าคน
มีขามากกว่าคนแล้วตัวนี้ล่ะคะ
อันนี้เป็นพวกแมลงค่ะแมลงเนี่ยก็จะมีขา
เนี่ยกี่ขาคะซูชิ 1
3  4
5  6 ค่ะ
มี 6 ขา
ใช่ค่ะถูกต้องค่ะแต่บางตัวน่าจะมีมากกว่า
นะอย่างอันนี้ 1  2
3  4
5  6
8 ก็คือ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะบลูชิแมลงหลายๆชนิดเนี่ยมันจะมี
หนวดค่ะหนวดที่ยื่นออกมาเหมือนเรดาร์ค่ะ
อันนี้คือหนวดใช่ค่ะ
นะของแมลงไม่ใช่ขานะไม่ใช่ขาค่ะ
นะเป็นหนวดค่ะ
เองก็มีหนวดค่ะครูปุ๊ก
ไหนล่ะครูชิมีหนวดที่ไหนกูก็ไม่เคยเห็น
เลย
มีหนวด
บ้างเดี๋ยวค่ะหนวดของคนกับหนวดของแมลง
เนี่ยมันไม่เหมือนกันค่ะ
แต่ว่ามันไม่ได้เป็นตัวจับเป็นเรดาร์อะไร
แบบนั้นน่าหนวดของคนเนี่ยมันไม่เหมือนของ
แมลงแมลงเนี่ยเวลามันจะหาของกินหรือว่า
บางทีมันจะส่งสัญญาณเป็นไม่รู้นะก็มันก็
จะเช็คด้วยหนวดเนี่ยแหละค่ะ
มันแรงเนี่ยมีหนวด
เหมือนกัน
หนวดกูชิไม่สวยเลยค่ะ
ไม่สวยหรอคะไม่สวยค่ะ
หนวดแมลงเนี่ยสวยกว่าค่ะ
ทำไมหนวดยาวมากเลย
ตัวนี้คือกุ๊กไม่ค่อยชอบเท่าไหร่ค่ะ
แมลงสาบ
แมลงปอ
เออ
แมลงกับแมลงมันไม่เหมือนกันหรอ
ไม่เหมือนค่ะ
แมลงอ่ะ
แมลงปอแมลงสาบ
[เพลง]
บางคนก็พูดผิดไง
แมงสาบ
แต่จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยแมลงเนี่ยมี 6 ขาค่ะมี
ขาเนี่ย 6 ขา
แต่ถ้าเป็นแมง
แมงเนี่ยก็จะมี 8 ขานะ
คะครูปุ๊กแมงมุม
เอ้า
แมงมุม
มีพริกทำไม
เยอะกว่านะคะ
8 ค่ะ
กู้ชีพไม่ได้เช็คอีก 2 ค่ะ
ก็ 2 ครูปุ๊กบอกมันอยู่ที่หัวเนี่ย
ถ้า 2 ที่มันอยู่ที่หัวมันคือหนวดค่ะ
เป็นหนวดมีหนวดเหมือนกันล่ะคะแมงเนี่ย
ใช่ค่ะแต่ถ้าเกิดมันอยู่ที่อก
ใช่ไหมมันมีหัวมีอกครูชี้แจงว่าไงหัวแล้ว
ก็มีอกอ่าอย่างงี้อกนะฮะแล้วมันจะมีขาออก
มา
อันนี้ขาค่ะ
แต่ถ้ามันออกมาจากหัวเนี่ยอันนี้หนวดค่ะ
อันนี้หนวด
หนวด
นะ
อันนี้คือหัวค่ะ
เห็นไหมมันก็อยู่ใกล้ๆปากเหมือนกัน
ก็อยู่ใกล้ๆป่า
ใช่ไหมแต่ปากมันอยู่ที่นี่หนวดมันไม่ได้
อยู่ที่นี่
อันนี้แมงมุมใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่แมลงมุมใช่ไหม
ไม่ใช่แมลงมุมค่ะ
ถ้าเกิดแมงเนี่ยมีขา 8 ขาถ้ามันแรงเนี่ย
มีขา 6 ขาค่ะ
[เพลง]
นอกจากแหม่มแมงมุมแล้วเนี่ยมีแมงอื่นมั้ย
ครูชี้
แมงป่องค่ะ
โอ้
แมงป่องเราก็ไม่พูดแมลงป่องใช่ไหมเราพูด
ว่าแมงป่องมีขา 8 ขาค่ะครูปุ๊ก 1  2  3  4
มันมาเป็นคู่ค่ะเห็นไหม
คู่กัน 6
คู่กัน 7
คู่กัน 8
แล้วบอกว่ามันมี 8 ขา
มี 8 ขา
หรือมี 4 คู่
4 คู่
4 คู่คู่
เหมือนเหมือนใส่รองเท้าไงรองเท้าก็ต้อง
ใส่เป็นคู่ใช่ไหมรองเท้าของเราอ่ะ
ใช่ไหมเราก็ใส่รองเท้าเนี่ยอันนี้คู่นึง
ต้องใส่รองเท้าไหมคะ
ไม่ต้องค่ะ
เพราะว่าขามันเนี่ยโอ้โหมันต้องแบบขามัน
จะมีขนค่ะไม่ใช่หนวดนะคะอันนี้ขน
ขนเห็นไหม
เพราะฉะนั้นมันไม่ลื่นมันไม่ลื่นค่ะ
มันไม่ต้องใส่รองเท้า
ถ้าอย่างนั้นเนี่ยมีสัตว์อะไรที่มีขามาก
กว่าแมงไหมโยชิ
จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยแมงป่องเนี่ยมันเหมือนอัน
นี้อีกทีเพราะว่ามันบางคนบอกว่ามันมีตรง
นี้
มันมีกล้ามเหมือนมือนะเหมือนๆมันมีมืออัน
นี้กล้าม
มันเหมือนสัตว์ตัวนี้เลยค่ะ
ที่ครูปุ๊กชอบกินค่ะ
ว่าปุ๊กชอบกิน
โอ้ชอบกินปูอันนี้ก็มีเห็นไหมนะมีขาเนี่ย
1  2  3  4
6  7
8 แล้วก็มีกล้ามอุ๊ย
อร่อยค่ะ
[เพลง]
อร่อยเพราะครูปุ๊กชอบกินปู
ใช่เยอะนะ
ใช่ปูก็มี 8 ขาเหมือนกันใช่ไหมแล้วก็มี
กล้าม 2 ก้ามนะ
กล้ามกล้ามเนื้อค่ะ
นะ
เรียกเหมือนกัน
เสียงมันคล้ายๆกันนะ
[เพลง]
อร่อยจริงๆปูอร่อย
โอ๊ยเดี๋ยวนักเรียนไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์จะบอก
ว่าครูใจร้าย
มากกว่านี้ค่ะ
กุ้งมีกี่ขาเหรอคะครูชิ
1  2  3  4  5 แล้วก็มีที่มันคู่กันมัน
เป็นคู่ใช่ไหม 5 คู่ 5 คู่มาเป็นคู่ใช่
มั้ย
มันก็ต้องคูณด้วย 2 ก็เท่ากับกุ้งมีทั้ง
หมด 10 ขาค่ะครูปุ๊ก
กุ้งก็มีขาเนี่ย 10 ขาเนี่ยมากกว่าแมง
เพราะแมงเนี่ยมี 8 ขา
แล้วก็มีมากกว่าแมลงแมลงเนี่ยมี 6 ขา
[เพลง]
แล้วเห็นไหมเหมือนกันค่ะ
ขาเนี่ยต้องอยู่ที่ตัวค่ะ
อันนี้ตัวส่วนที่อยู่ที่หัวเนี่ยตรงนี้
เราไม่เรียกขา
เราเรียกหนวด
หนวด
หนวดกุ้ง
เยอะนะ
มากกว่าแมง
มากว่าแมลง
[เพลง]
เอออันนี้เป็นแคมเปี้ยนไปเลยนะ
ไม่ใช่นะ
มันต้องมีสัตว์ที่มีขามากกว่า 10 ขาแน่ๆ
เลยค่ะ
โรชิอะไรคะที่มีขามากกว่า 10 ขาอีก
ก็จะมีนี่ไง
มันเป็นหนอนมันมีเยอะค่ะ
นอนมันมีแบบเยอะมากหนอน
หนอนที่มีขา 6 ขาเหมือนๆแมลงใช่ไหมแต่
หนอนตัวนี้อย่าเพิ่งนะก่อน 1  2  3
4  5
มี 8 คู่ 8
ว้าว
หนอนบางตัวมีขา 6 ขาบางตัวมี 16 ขา
เหรอแสดงว่าหนอนเนี่ยก็จะมีขายเยอะนะตั้ง
แต่ 6 ขาก็มีเนาะนะหรือว่า 16 ขาก็มีเอ่อ
นะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยหนอนก็ไม่เหมือนกันนะ
แต่หนอนเนี่ย
อร่อยไหมคะ
อันนี้น่าจะไม่กินค่ะคุณโอชิมันมี
ขนๆเนี่ยมันทำให้คันค่ะตรงนี้ใช่ไหมขนๆ
ตรงนี้ของมันน่ะใช่มั้ย
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ไม่มีค่ะ
ที่มันมีขามากกว่า 16 ขาค่ะ
นี่ไง
โอ้โห
อันนั้นมันขาคนเนี่ย
หาคนไม่ใช่ขาอันนี้ตัวนี้มีขาแบบเยอะมาก
อันนี้คือตะขาบ
ตะขาบปลาคาร์ฟมีขากี่ขาคะโฮชินับซิ
1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10  11  12
13  14  15  16  17  18  19 หรอคะ
อุ๊ยมี 20 ด้วยเอ้ยไม่ใช่
ใช่
20 คูณ 2 มันต้องเป็นคู่ใช่ไหม
มันมีด้านขวาแล้วก็มีด้านซ้ายตรงนี้อีก
โอ้มีด้านซ้ายด้วย
ใช่มั้ยเพราะฉะนั้นคิดว่ามันน่าจะเหมือน
กันกับหนอนค่ะที่อาจจะมีขาเนี่ยไม่เท่า
กันเพราะว่าถ้าเนี่ยมันมีทั้งตัวเล็กๆตัว
ใหญ่ๆนะบางตัวเนี่ยเล็กนะตัวสั้นๆแต่มีขา
เนี่ยเยอะกว่าอีกนะ
เพราะฉะนั้น
ตะขาบมีขาตั้งแต่กี่ขาขึ้นไปค่ะ
ตั้งแต่ 20 ขา
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
เป็นแชมป์เปี้ยน
แต่ตะขาบยังไม่เหมือนหนอนนะไม่มีขนแต่
กูชิเนี่ยเห็นผลไง
บางคนเนี่ยไม่ได้เลยนะ
ICU เลย
เพราะว่ามันมีพิษใช่ไหมมันมีพิษ
งู
ถ้างูเห่าใช่ไหม
Cobra
King ของป้าอย่างนี้มีพิษค่ะ
นะงูเห่างูจงอาง
ถ้าถูกมันกัดมันก็มีพิษเข้าไปค่ะ
คนก็ตายค่ะตายได้ค่ะไม่เป็นไร
ที่นี่กูชิก็ต้องรับเอาเชือกมารัดตรงนี้
ค่ะ
เออเดี๋ยวเอาไว้ลองมาสอนนักเรียนดีกว่า
เทคนิค
ถ้าเกิดมันกัดหัวแล้วก็มัดคอ
อันนั้นไม่ต้องไปหาหมอแล้วค่ะ
ตาย
ใช่แต่ว่าขาเนี่ย
มันต้องมีมากกว่านี้ค่ะ
ที่มีขามากกว่า 20 ขาแน่ๆเลยอ้าวมีมีอะไร
ที่มากกว่านี้อีกเหรอคะมี Champion มาก
กว่านี้หรอ
ก็จะมี
ตัวคล้ายๆกันใช่ไหมซูชิ
[เพลง]
มันไม่มีขาคือมันไม่มีขากิ้งกือใช่ไหม
ใช่กิ้งกือเนี่ยมีขาเยอะน่ะ
ไม่ใช่ขนนะคะเป็นขาของมัน
นี่ขามันหรอ
ใช่ค่ะ
นั่นแหละเยอะมากเดี๋ยวกูชิต้องต้องไปบอก
มันว่าอันไหนลองยืดดูขาหน่อยซิ
นับค่ะ
ตรงนี้ก็ 10 แล้วค่ะ
20  30  40  50  60
ก็โอ๊ยเป็นเป็นร้อยค่ะครูปุ๊ก
แล้วมันยังเป็นคู่อีกอ่ะ
เป็นร้อยๆเลยค่ะ
ใช่
มากกว่า 100 นะ
มากกว่านะคะ
ให้มันเป็นแชมเปี้ยนไปเถอะ
1  2  3  4  5  6  7 โหยนับไม่ไหวครับ
ครูปุ๊ก
เรายังไม่เห็นทั้งหมด 100% นะ
แค่อาจจะ 50%
30% ไม่รู้เลย
อืมอ่าเนี่ย
[ปรบมือ]
Champion ค่ะ
ขายมากที่สุด
ในโลกค่ะสัตว์ตัวนี้คือแชมเปี้ยน
เป็นคู่กันแล้ว
นะมา 1 ต้องแล้วมีคู่กันมีขาข้างในอีก
แล้วตัวยาวขนาดนี้กี่เมตร
1,36 ขา
เยอะมากที่สุดค่ะก็คือกิ้งกือที่
ออสเตรเลีย
แชมป์
ขามีสัตว์ที่มีขาเยอะมากเป็นพันขาสงสัยจะ
วิ่งเก่ง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ถ้าซื้อรองเท้าใส่นี่ไม่รู้ไม่ต้องใส่นาน
เท่าไหร่นะ
ทำรองเท้าขายกิ้งกือนะคะ
รองเท้าให้กิ้งกือใส่เนี่ยเราเวลาขายรอง
เท้าขายรองเท้าให้คนเนี่ยได้คู่หนึ่งขาย
รองเท้าให้หมาให้แมวได้ 4
กิ้งกือได้เป็นพันเลยนะ
แต่ตอนนี้เราต้องมากวนหน่อยสิ
ว่าเรามีนะสัตว์อะไรบ้างคะเราได้แชมป์
แล้วใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้เป็นแชมป์เปี้ยนค่ะขากิ้งกือ
ค่ะ
กิ้งกือ
ตะขาบ
หนอน
กุ้ง
ปู
[เพลง]
แมงมุม
แมลง
ช้าง
หมา
หมาหมา
แมว
นก
เป็ด
ไก่
หอยทากหอยทาก
งู
คน
นะ
ในโลกนี้
แต่
ครูปุ๊กคิดว่าคนมีแค่ 2 ขาเนี่ยพอดีแล้ว
ค่ะไม่ต้องมีเยอะกว่านี้ค่ะ
ขนาดคนมี 2 ขาเดินๆยังแบบสะดุด
ล้มเลย
ถ้าคนมีขายเยอะๆนะขาเยอะๆเนี่ยโอ้โหไม่
รู้จะใช้ยังไง
ซูชิก็อาจจะมีแค่ 2 ไงก็เลยหกล้มใช่ไหม
แต่ถ้า 4 เนี่ยมันก็
นะมันก็พอดีไงล็อกไว้หมดทุกด้านไม่เป็นไร
ค่ะ
[เพลง]
เราเลยเวลาแล้วโอเค
อันนี้เป็นเรื่องของการเปรียบเทียบ
ว่าคนเนี่ยมี 2 ขามีสัตว์บางตัวที่มีขา
น้อยกว่าคนและมีสัตว์บางตัวที่มีขามาก
กว่าคนและมีสัตว์บางตัวที่มีขาเท่ากับคน
ก็วันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะเรามาพบกันใหม่
ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะขอบคุณค่ะ
[เพลง]
บ๊ายบาย